Is there any specific things you would tell me?
Like things I should say when I go into that next interview?
I would do an audit of your personality traits that match and your skills that match.
Literally, write them down on a piece of paper.
If you're interested in a job, there will be connections.
Friendly, generous, divergent, darkly funny, creative (in capital letters),...
...curious, competitive and collaborative.
Do your homework.
Make sure you know about not only the job description but the company itself.
One thing I really recommend is you do what I call effective practice.
And you don't need a mirror.
You don't need a friend.
You could do it in your closet or your bathroom.
Just several times, try to practice getting those points out together...
...in a very confident, clear and simple way.
So, I think I worked pretty hard this week and I hope you're proud, so...
But I'm already proud of you, so don't worry about that part.
Number two is, I guess that leaves one question.
And that is: Christine, why don't you tell me a little bit about yourself?
Certainly. So, as you can see, I've been an editor for a while.
And I love working in teams...
...to tell a story very creatively and intelligently to our readers.
But also, make it make sense for the business.
And I work really well and collaborate with people from all over the organization.
I think I'm a pretty friendly person.
And it's really important that I establish trust with others.
I know that one of your company core values...
...is creative intelligence and productive teamwork.
And for that reason, I think that I'd be great for this job.
That's terrific, Christine.